( intro music )
( applause )
When we put together the
proposal for this talk,
I suspected that many people
would be wondering about
this pair, pairing of
data and the wilderness,
because I think the way we
think about those two words,
they're quite far apart.
We don't think of those things
being paired together but...
I hope that we'll find out
over the next few minutes that
that they actually do go
very well together indeed.
The word data, we hear
this word every day now.
And it's something that's become
really ubiquitous in our lives.
The definition of data
is fairly simple.
Data are measurements
of something.
But it... the word
itself has become
something much
more than that.
And what I want to
talk about today is
I want to talk about
the idea of data
paired with this
concept of distance.
- I estimated here
- ( audience laughter )
and I think
I estimated generously,
but standing in front of
you in this crowd today
the hippo in question
was somewhere about
the middle of the crowd.
And, some hippo data,
in case you don't know
a male hippo, they're the,
mostly the angry ones.
They weigh about three
and a half tons.
They're five feet tall
and 13 feet long.
- This is an angry minivan.
- ( audience laughter )
It may surprise you
from looking at me but
I was not a rugged explorer
type when I was a child.
( audience laughter )
And I spent
most of that time
exploring through the computer.
And since then I've used
the computer and tools
that have been created
to make art with the computer.
And, I started to use data.
The simple examples are these
stylized charts and graphs.
This is a graph showing
the frequency of the words
"communism" at the bottom
and "terrorism" at the top
in the New York Times
between 1980 and 2010.
Now, all of this
hinges on the fact
that data is a deeply
human artifact.
There would be no data
without humans. We create it.
Our normal understanding of this
is something quite different.
And so when Steve approached
me to work on this project,
one of the primarily exci--
things that I was very
much excited about here was
how can we remind
people of the humans
that are on this expedition
and how can we track them
at the same time that we're
tracking the wildlife
which is the primary
focus of the science.
And while I was at
the New York Times ,
I was at the Times for
two and a half years
as their data artist
in residence,
I produced along with a
couple of collaborators
a project called "Open Paths".
It allows you to do exactly
what every other app
in your pocket does
but with one big difference.
And that is that
you can turn around
and look at the data first.
And second, nobody owns
that data except for you.
So, we built this project.
I installed "Open Paths"
on my phone
and kind of forgot about it.
And about a month later,
I came back to the website
where you can view your own data
and see where you've been.
And I realized that this data
that I was tracking
represents something that's
fundamentally important to me
which is my
own personal narrative.
The actual story of my life.
And... and with the website
you can
make a couple of
different comparisons
with it, it's a really
straight forward visualization.
But thinking about
what this data is
started to bring me towards
what I think is
the most important question
in my practice
which is, "how can I build
a personal relationship
between me and my data?"
And my goal and the goal
with this project is to
remind us of that and also to
bring that gulf between
data and humans closer together.
Now, in this
closeness that to...
the wilderness that
Steve described,
as much as I have tried
to prepare myself for
was impossible to prepare
for the reality.
So, this is us, we are
strapped in, in these
portage harnesses
and we are pulling these mokoro
some of which weigh well over
500 pounds through sticky mud.
The reeds are razor sharp,
our legs are covered
in blood and leeches.
It's 110 degrees and, and...
and we really have become
one with this environment.
But at the same time our
goal, Shah's goal, my goal
was to collect data at
every moment that we can.
So, this is Shah
in his field station,
an upturned
Tupperware bin
and he is recording water
quality measurements
that we then upload
to our website.
And we would also in the
evening, we would
try to get as much of the
record of the day as we could
sorted out and depending
on our bandwidth analysis,
get that up into the website.
And what we were trying to do, I
think, for the first time was
to build a truly live
data expedition.
Now these little
colorful dots that
you've been seeing on the side
of the screen are actually
data points that we collected
during the expedition.
Each one of them representing
a sighting of a species.
So, as we are traveling
down the river,
something amazing was
happening and that was
with every data point
that we were collecting
was uploaded via satellite
to the website
generally within
five to ten minutes
and it was available
to the public.
So the public could
not only see
those data points appearing
on the map
they could use them
in their research,
in their classrooms
and our goal here
was to try to bring
the wilderness to
the real world.
So this is how it'd work.
This is an African Skimmer,
actually quite a rare bird.
It has an adaptation in it's
beak which allows it to
skim the surface and catch
insects from the water.
So, we may stumble upon
three African Skimmers
and Steve would say
Steve: Three Skimmers.
Jer Thorp: Giles, who is sitting
in front of him
in the boat, would use
a custom made Android app
that we built for the expedition
to report this sighting
of three Skimmers.
That would send the data
to a little Raspberry Pi.
A Raspberry Pi is a
$30 computer that
we built inside of a
little pelican case
that sat in the
back of the boat.
And that little antenna
that you see
is talking up to
the satellite.
So the data would immediately
be sent up to the satellite
to the website, where it
would appear for the public.
It's something that
we're really proud of
because it allows people at any
point during the expedition
to come in and really feel
what this experience is like
to understand the
time-based nature of it,
difference between
these sparse Papyrus canals
that we were travelling
through the first days
to the central delta where
the wildlife concentrations
are bigger and denser than
almost any other place on Earth.
This is the fundamental
idea of the project.
Can we turn the idea
on its head that
the reason why scientists
go into-- go into the field,
the reason why they go on
expeditions is so that
they can gather data that
no other scientist has.
And that's the
fundamental reason
why expeditions are
appealing to scientists.
Because they are going to be
able to get access to something
that nobody else has seen.
So, with our project,
we flipped that.
Right away,
as soon as we're making our
measurements in the field
this data is available
not only to our team
but to any other research team
who may not have the budget
to get into the Okavango
and to anybody else
who is interested in this
wilderness area.
So, what you're
seeing here is
every species
sighting that we saw
along the actual track
of the expedition.
So we can look for
pattern in species
we can see how this is
changing over time.
And the idea is to
build this tool
into something that
anybody can use.
Our number one focus is
to make all this open.
We are also building
these sensor platforms.
These are a couple
of the sensor platforms
before they were deployed.
This is one of
the test sensor platforms
after it's been deployed.
And if I had my cell phone
with me, I don't right now,
I can actually go and look at
the API right now and I can get
an accurate pH and temperature
measurement from this
body of water in the Okavango
from right here on stage
and anybody can do that.
And next year we are hoping
to deploy a network of up to
fifty of these sensors
throughout the delta
so anybody...
scientists, the curious, can get
a look at this ecosystem.
One of our challenges is
how do we get more people
involved in this project.
And one of the things that we've
been working on with Shah
is to take the
underlying infrastructure
of the "Into The Okavango"
project and to release it
as a fundamentally
open source project
that any other
expeditionary scientist can use.
So, we're starting to
work on this right now.
The "Open Data Field Kit"
will be available to anybody
to be able to do the same things
that we're doing in the delta
other wilderness areas,
in other urban areas, so that
data could be something that
automatically gets shared
with the public.
And our intent here is to
produce a data legacy.
We want to produce a data
legacy for everybody.
For teachers, for students,
for artists, for designers
for researchers, for anybody who
wants to use this information.
Because as important as our
travels into the delta are,
they are going to have
limited impact
if we can't get this out
to everybody.
And it's simple
to get involved.
You can follow us on, on...
on our Twitter feed which is
"@IntoTheOkavango".
You can follow the website.
And together we can try
to bring these three
seemingly disparate
things together.
- Now... I know I didn't finish.
- ( audience laughter )
We're all wearing these
heart-rate sensors on our arms
which are recording
our biometrics and--
( chuckles )
So, I actually do have an exact
record of what it's like
to be charged by a hippo.
And I'm going to let you
listen to it. So...
- I'm on the right
- ( audience laughter )
and you are going to hear the
actual in-time heartbeat.
I'm going to start it and it's
going to pause for a second
and then it's going to play
up to when the hippo charges.
I'm not even going to
tell you what time it is
because it's obvious.
( heart-rate monitor beeps )
( monitor beeps faster )
( beeps getting even faster )
( audience laughter )
Now, I want to point
something out
because Steve is
sitting right here.
He said that he was
concerned about me
but look at his heart-rate.
( audience laughter )
He's cool as a cucumber
over there
in the front boat.
And I hope this leaves us with
an example and a reminder
of the things that we can
do through this project
and through changing our
understanding of data
to bring us from a place,
where this information
is something made by machines,
this information that
is something that is
cold and numerical,
to being something that can be
shared, can be talked about,
can be performed, can
be used to tell stories,
can be used to teach,
can be used to inspire.
As Steve said our mission in
the Okavango is critical.
We have two years to
cha-- to make change,
to make sure that this pristine
environment remains pristine
and I can really think of
no more important goal.
So, please join us as
we enter the Okavango again
and follow along
with the experience,
both through the data and
through your ability to...
to connect to us as
explorers and we hope that
we'll have some more stories
to tell for you next year.
Thank you.
( applause )